[Musique]
bonjour à tous la force des républicains
c'est son réseau d'élus locaux sur tout
le territoire national en métropole
comme en outre-mer sur la volonté de
christian jacob nous venons de lancer le
comité des mères qui a pour vocation de
structurer la famille des élus locaux
sur l'ensemble de notre territoire
national en métropole comme en outre-mer
je vous invite à aller sur le site des
républicains télécharger la liste des
correspondants départementaux pour
trouver votre référent et découvrir à
l'échelle de nos territoires les actions
qui sont portés par les élus locaux
action exemplaire pendant cette période
de crise dans tous les domaines qui font
le quotidien de la vie de nos
concitoyens
nous avons cette chance chez les
républicains d'avoir un réseau de mer le
plus fort de l'ensemble des familles
politiques présentes sur notre
territoire
c'est pour nous cette force de l'exemple
cette force de l'investissement les
valeurs qui sont les nôtres du travail
du mérite que nous déployons au
quotidien dans menu dans nos
municipalités sur eux aujourd'hui de
partager ses expériences avec vous et
vous demander à vous aux militants
sympathisants de parler autour de vous
de ce qui se fait à l'échelon local du
talent de nos mères et de donner envie à
celles et ceux qui sont pas encore
adhérent aux républicains de nous
rejoindre je compte sur vous mercier
[Musique]